welcome back everyone David Neil Minh is
still with us and we're joined now by
bio physicist and venture capitalist dr.
Andrew bogan dr. bogan I'm just going to
hand it over to you where would you like
to pick that up what would you like to
add to what's already been discussed
well I think you've captured very well
the importance of doing prevalence
testing on broad population samples and
really understanding where we are with
this disease Steve I think that's not
known
I think studies like ours which can be
replicated very quickly around the
country and around the world should be
done and will help inform what the real
numbers look like so I just wanted to
ask you to comment on the this is a
critical time we all need to be clear
about that decisions are being made
about what comes after the April 30th
national guidelines people are wrestling
with this question about how do we
reopen our economies I just would like
your take dr. bogan on that on the on
the two plans let's just start with the
Scott Gottlieb plan which seems to me a
lot of people are getting behind in
Washington and elsewhere which is let's
test everyone virus test everyone and
then we can isolate the people who have
the virus and trace their contacts and
so on and manage this going forward dr.
pouchy seems to be very keen on that
approach what do you make of it so
testing is important but we have to
realize that there may be a lot of
people who have already had this disease
that you will not be able to test with a
PCR test for active virus there the
traditional testing that's been done
you'll only be able to tech that they
already had this virus if you use the
Sarah logic test like the one we did or
a laboratory version of it like the one
being developed at Stanford now but I
don't think it's going to be practical
if the numbers of infections are as
large as they might be as you suggested
earlier to be doing contact tracing for
every single infection on a global basis
I just think that there's a very real
chance here that this disease has
progressed much further than we realize
based on the undercounting biases of the
way we've been doing testing so far and
if we were able to discover that that
were the case I am very hesitant to say
that it would be feasible to contract
trace every single infections contacts
that's an incredibly important point you
made it really clearly we have to
underline that because this seems to be
the direction our policymakers are going
in the other one David let me bring you
in on this is this idea of antibody
immunity certificates that say well if
you've had it you can go back to work
but if the other person your household
hasn't had the virus they just still
have to stay in the shutdown what do you
make of that David well I you know I'd
like you meant you should you couldn't
have said it better
you know Steve went when you in your
opening monologue you know you can't you
can't let people go back to work if they
don't have it because it creates this
perverse incentive that you're gonna go
out and try and get sick especially if
you know you're not gonna get that sick
but it could create a much bigger crisis
I mean just that just add you know
something that Andrew just said you know
about about about the mass testing you
know if 50% of the people who have it
who had it didn't even know they had it
and if 85% of the people had a mild case
of it never got tested how can you trace
50% of the people who had it and didn't
even know they had it that's that's just
a that's crazy I mean you can see why
these numbers that are coming out of
there's a there's a tent a study out of
Denmark that shows up to 30 to 80 times
as many people that were tested have
have the antibodies there's a test out
there's a study out of Germany that says
fifteen percent of this town you know
already has it which is something that's
like a hundred times what the the German
test rate is today so you know it's you
know like Andrew said this has probably
gone way beyond that and we should
really focus our efforts now on
identifying who's really at risk and
taking care of those people that's what
we should really be doing